i mean it's a risk to allow them to to
to carry out you know crimes against
humanity while we're standing by and not
doing anything to stop it
because after all ukraine is a friendly
country to us
right
and that would embolden them to try the
same thing with countries like estonia
latvia lithuania much better to try to
stop it now
than to have to stop it under much worse
conditions you know someplace else
so
are you saying
that
best case scenario would be regime
change in russia that's absolutely the
best case scenario but it's something
they and it could happen but it won't
happen because what we do
it'll happen that that's up to the
russian people
and by the way it's not unrealistic
because after 18 months of war in
chechnya
the russian people were
were ready to with draw troops from
chechnya at any price
at any and just
even if it meant complete surrender
and yeltsin at that time said that he
could he could not win re-election if if
if the war was not not brought to an end
and he did bring it to an end and they
did withdraw isn't biden already talking
about regime change though i mean well
he made a mistake he made a he made a
comment that we've got to get rid of
this guy uh referring to and the white
house tried to try to like save trying
to
walk it back and he came out again
saying no absolutely he's a butcher he
called him a butcher yeah well you know
none of that makes much difference to
tell you the honest truth he can say
anything he wants i mean the the the uh
but what is that doesn't that give
doesn't that give russia a stronger hand
like look look
he wants regime change
don't you think that feeds into their
propaganda isn't that what they want
well they'll use that in their
propaganda oh yeah sure in their
propaganda inside the country but it's
not critical to their propaganda they've
been you know they're they are uh
doesn't it they've been they've they've
been saying that anyway
they've been saying that even without
biden's of course but this proves it
right
yeah i mean
the thing is that the the you know the
the real situation is the the
destabilization is not any is not the
result of any words that biden says
but rather the fact that they've
attacked a country with you know 120
thousand or 150 000 troops and are
bombing indiscriminately and killing
civilians
and uh this country which was at peace
with them and was not threatening them
what happens if we do get regime change
in russia and now we're in now we have
some sort of a
president in russia that
is an ally to us
and that i don't think any any any any
country any change from what i know
about the internal political situation
in russia
nobody who replaces putin if someone if
someone replaces him
will be an a a a a
a
uh
a puppet of the united states it would
no no it would it would have to be
someone
the opposition would have to come from
the military and the security services
on the grounds that putin was destroying
the country and the the war had to stop
in order to save russia
and under those circumstances uh those
people uh
uh you know they would they would not
necessarily uh be friendly to the west
or to the us and they would cause
trouble but they would try to they would
try to
re-establish some kind you know get the
kind the economy back on its feet and
end the war and and uh
and end the end the existing crisis
uh
but uh whether those forces are strong
enough to do that we don't know because
that we know they exist
we know they exist because before the uh
before the invasion general leonid
ivashov
who is a very high-ranking retired
general was was very high-ranking and is
now the head of a an association of
retired military and intelligence
officers in russia
uh said publicly that a a war with
ukraine would be an absolute disaster
and it was just being undertaken to prop
up this senescent regime
and
uh and you know the the members of the
board of this organization supported him
now if these guys were willing to say
that publicly then you can be sure that
that opinion opinion is held in the
military by a lot of people who just
aren't don't feel that they can express
themselves
[Music]
so i mean the the the sentiment exists
the people exist
uh they're you know from what we
understand that there's surveillance uh
going on inside the leadership everyone
is being spied on a bond but
you know they could the you know if the
city if russia suffers
catastrophic defeats they could they
could
intervene and find enough support to
remove putin inside the country without
the u.s having anything to do with it
if i'm thinking from the us's point of
view
if we want resi if we do want if the
goal is true that we do want regime
change in russia
that's a huge risk no matter who gets in
because anyone in control of all those
nuclear weapons is a massive risk not
only to the us but to the world so
wouldn't the us's first priority would
be to declaw so to speak russia and get
rid of those or take possession of all
of the news we don't have the ability to
do that and it isn't even necessary i
mean what's necessary right now is is is
to end the war
to get the russians to withdraw and to
get a peace settlement that that will be
uh
that they will respect and that will
uh
you know
assure the integrity of ukraine
that would
under those conditions i mean if
something like that can be worked out
and it's you know tall order
then the next step of course is to you
know slowly re-establish economic
relations and try to kind of get this
yeah which would which of course you get
you know that would that would benefit
everybody
i think that after this experience
though the the the the dependency
of the west on russian energy is going
to be a lot less
because we've seen the risks
and i think there'll be a much greater
drive toward diversification of source
of energy sources on the part of
countries like germany which is you know
the
pivotal very pivotal country
well david we just did over three hours
wow
that's all i can say i want to thank you
for coming here and providing your
insight
and your knowledge and uh on behalf of
all the listeners and viewers
um
if you could
give people
an idea where they could find some of
your work your books your articles
anything that you're doing well amazon i
mean just type in my name you'll see all
the books are on amazon.com
okay
and uh
and the internet is is full of my
articles and uh
so is youtube and uh
it's not hard
awesome